♪
PRIMARY BATTLES SETTING THE
STAGE FOR WHAT IS SURE TO BE A
BLOCKBUSTER MIDTERM ELECTION.
IT IS STILL DOWN TO THE WIRE IN
PENNSYLVANIA WHERE DAVE
McCORMICK AND DR. OZ ARE NOT,
AND NECK AND ONLY SEPARATED BY
JUST A FEW THOUSAND VOTES.
BOTH CANDIDATES ARE CONFIDENT A
VICTORY.
>> WHEN ALL THE VOTES ARE
TALLIED THOSE TALLIED, I AM
CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL WIN.
>> WE ARE MAKING A FEROCIOUS
CHARGE.
BUT WHEN IT IS THIS CLOSE, WHAT
ELSE CAN YOU EXPECT?
EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS CAMPAIGN
HAS BEEN TIGHT.
>> WE KNEW IT WAS WORKING.
WE KNEW OUR MESSAGE.
>> WE CAN SEE THE PATH AHEAD.
WE CAN SEE VICTORY AHEAD.
>> IT WAS A BIG NIGHT FOR OTHER
TREBEK CANDIDATES IN
PENNSYLVANIA, NORTH CAROLINA,
WHICH IS A CONTRAST TO PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
JOHN FETTERMAN AND TIM RYAN HAVE
KEPT THEIR BUSINESS FROM THE BIG
GUY.
KELLYANNE CONWAY KNOWS WHY.
>> THIS IS THE REFLECTION OF
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THE TWO
POLITICAL PARTIES.
EVERYONE WANTS DONALD TRUMP'S
ENDORSEMENT.
JOHN FETTERMAN AND THAT
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE, HE DOES NOT
WANT JOE BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN WHEN TO THE STATE AND
HE WAS NEVER TO BE FOUND AND HE
SHOWED UP IN HIS SHORTS AND
SWEATSHIRTS.
THEY DON'T WANT THEM CAMPAIGNING
WITH THEM.
AND IT TELLS YOU THE TALE OF THE
TWO PARTIES RIGHT NOW.
>> THAT COMES AS MR. UNITY THOSE
NEGATIVE.
CLAIMING PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
FINALLY GOING TO TRY TO STOP
WORKING WITH THE GOP AND INSTEAD
GO ON THE ATTACK.
HE LOOKS TO CREATE A CONTRAST
BETWEEN HIS JOB PERFORMANCE AND
ULTRA MAGA CANDIDATES.
DANA, WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION?
>> Dana: HOW MUCH TIME ARE YOU
GOING TO GIVE ME HERE?
ONE, IF YOU LOOK AT THAT SENATE
RACE IN NORTH CAROLINA, THE
TRUMP BACKED CANDIDATE THERE RAN
AWAY WITH IT.
I MEAN, THE CAN'T RENT AWAY WITH
THAT SPOON.
THERE WAS NO QUESTION THAT THAT
WAS GOING TO GO IN 10 BUT'S WAY.
MEDICINE COMFORT LOSING, THAT IS
SOMETHING.
THIS IS A YOUNG MAN WHO MAY BE
HEAT -- SEE WHERE HE IS IN FIVE
YEARS.
DOES HE TAKE THIS EXPERIENCE AND
DECIDE TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
ONE OF THE THINGS HE SAID HE
DECIDED TO HIRE MOSTLY
COMMUNICATIONS PEOPLE.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THAT, YOU
DON'T HAVE VICTORIES TO RENT,
ACCOMPLISHMENT'S TO RUN AND YOU
END UP GETTING VICIOUSLY
ATTACKED.
I'M NOT SAYING -- BUT HE IS NO
LONGER THERE.
I THINK THE PENNSYLVANIA RACE IS
SOMETHING THAT IS JUST SO
INTERESTING.
ONE ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE, IF I
COULD COMMENT ON THE DEMOCRATS
WITH QUICK.
JOHN FETTERMAN, ALSO THE CAT RAN
AWAY WITH THE SPOON IN THAT ONE.
CONOR LAMB WAS CONSIDERED THAT
YOU WOULD THINK THAT PERFECT
CANDIDATE.
PERFECT A MODERATE DEMOCRAT IN A
STATE LIKE PENNSYLVANIA.
YOU COULD ALSO RUB ELBOWS WITH
THE TECH GUYS THAT WANT TO BUILD
MORE COMPANIES AND IN
PENNSYLVANIA AND PITTSBURGH AND
HE JUST COULD NEVER GET ANY
TRACTION.
SO JOHN FETTERMAN, LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR TEXT ENDS UP IN THE
HOSPITAL.
THIS GUY, THOUGH, ABSOLUTELY
DESTROYED CONOR LAMB.
THIS TELL YOU -- TELLS YOU WHERE
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS GOING.
HE IS AN ORIGINAL BERNIE ROPER
HE WANTS MEDICARE FOR ALL AND HE
IS GOING TO BE TAGGED AS A
SOCIALIST.
I'M TELLING YOU THAT REPUBLICANS
SHOULD NOT SLEEP ON HIM BECAUSE
THIS RACE IS GOING TO BE REALLY
TIGHT.
PENNSYLVANIA WILL REMAIN TIGHT.
ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE OF THINGS
THAT THERE'S ONLY ONE CANDIDATE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE THAT HAS
ONE PENNSYLVANIA SINCE 1988.
AND THAT WAS DONALD TRUMP.
AND HE RAN A RACE THAT WAS
DIFFERENT.
IT WAS WILD.
PEOPLE -- HE CREATED THIS
AMAZING BASE OF SUPPORT.
AND ANY REPUBLICAN WHO IS NOT
HIM HAS TO RUN A NEAR PERFECT
RACE.
MITCH McCONNELL SAID HE
BELIEVES WHO OUR WINS INTENSIVE
UNIONS THAT THEY FEEL STRONGLY
THAT THEY CAN WIN IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
I WOULD TELL YOU I THINK THAT
THEY WILL MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE THIS AND THEY MIGHT HAVE A
RECOUNT.
JOHN FETTERMAN'S CAMPAIGN IS
ALREADY OFF.
>> OH, FETTERMAN.
HE IS ABOUT YOUR SIZE, I THINK
THAT 6'9", SHORTER.
HE DOES NOT LIKE SUITS.
HE WEARS SWEATS.
>> I LIKE HIM IN THE SENSE THAT
HE IS DIFFERENT.
LOOKING AT WHAT I SAW WAS A
FEVER OF JUST BATTLES FROM
REPUBLICANS WHO HAD VOTES GOING
3D.
WHICH MEANS THE NUMBERS GET WHEN
YOU LOOK AT WHO WAS SHOWING UP
TO VOTE, THAT MEMBERS OF
REPUBLICANS WHO WERE COMING UP
TO VOTE, I DON'T HEAR IF YOU ARE
SEPARATE MEANT.
SHOULD BE AFRAID BECAUSE YES,
YOUR CAMPAIGN IS GETTING STARTED
EARLY.
BUT THE SHEER NUMBERS, THIRD
PLACE IS RUNNING STRONG.
WHICH MEANS THAT WHEN ALL OF
THEM COME TOGETHER AND I THINK
THEY WILL COME TOGETHER.
I THINK THE REPUBLICANS GETS IT.
THEY KNOW.
THEY HAVE SEEN WHAT IS GOING ON.
THEY WANT RACE.
BACK.
THEY WANT TO GET INFLATION DOWN.
THEY WANT TO GET AMERICA BACK.
I'M JUST LOOKING AT HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE SHOWING UP AT THE
BALLOT AND IT IS A HUGE
DIFFERENCE.
I THINK THE ONLY ONES WHO ARE
SHOWING UP FOR THE DEMOCRATS ARE
THE PROGRESSIVES BECAUSE
MODERATES ARE GOING, YOU KNOW
WHAT?
WE ARE BETTER OFF WITH THE OTHER
GUYS.
>> YOU THINK THE REPUBLICANS ARE
GOING TO COALESCED AROUND
McCORMICK OR WHOEVER IT IS?
>> I DO.
I THINK THAT JOHN FETTERMAN
PROBABLY DOES NOT WANT TO GO UP
AGAINST MEHMET OZ BECAUSE NOT
ONLY IS HE IN A REALLY TOUGH
PRIMARY, HE HAS NAME THE
CONDITION AND IF YOUR TALK ABOUT
SOCIALIZED MEDICINE, HEAT,
BETTER TO DISSECT WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT HAS DONE TO RUIN
HEALTHCARE IN THIS COUNTRY THAN
A DOCTOR WHO HAS ENRICHED
HIMSELF IN THE FREE MARKET THAT
NOT ONLY IN MEDICINE BUT IN
ENTERTAINMENT AS WELL.
SO HE REALLY CARES ABOUT THAT
ISSUE AND I HOPE HE PINS JOHN
FETTERMAN COUNT ON THIS BECAUSE
WHAT INFLATION WHERE IT IS AT
AND TAXES, TAX HIKE ON THE
HORIZON, YOU COMPOUND THAT WITH
MEDICARE FOR ALL, WE CANNOT
AFFORD THAT.
THE HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY CANNOT
SO YES, I DO THINK IT IS GOING
TO BE VERY TOUGH.
I THOUGHTS WAS INTERESTING
BECAUSE HE HAD BEEN POLLING
AHEAD.
I THOUGHT PERHAPS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S ENDORSEMENT OF HIM
LAST MINUTE MIGHT HELP.
BUT HE SO FAR LOST ONLY BY A
COUPLE PERCENTAGE POINTS.
THERE HAS TO BE SOMETHING THERE.
IT HAS TO BE SUBSTANTIVE.
THERE HAS TO BE POLICY BEHIND
THE PERSON.
WE CAN NO LONGER BECOME ATTACHED
TO PEOPLE BECAUSE OF THEIR
CHARACTERISTICS OR THEIR
INTERESTING LIFE STORIES, HOW
THEY LEAD AND HOW THEY -- IS FAR
MORE IMPORTANT.
>> GERALDO, LOOKING AT THE
ENDORSEMENT, DOES DONALD TRUMP
STILL HAVE THAT MAGIC TOUCH?
>> Geraldo: NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
MY STAGE IN OHIO, EVERYONE WAS
LOOKING FOR DONALD TRUMP TO
ENDORSE HIM AND VERY, VERY -- HE
HAD A COUPLE OF MISSES HERE AND
THERE.
BUT I MUST SAY, QUICK POINTS.
JOHN FETTERMAN IS ENORMOUSLY
CHARISMATIC.
AND I BELIEVE THAT HE WILL CROSS
OVER.
IT IS NOT JUST PROGRESSIVES.
PSAKI IS A VERY COOL GUY.
I LIKE HIM A LOT.
I ENDORSE HIM.
IF I COULD ENDORSE DR. OZ, ONE
FRIEND OF MINE.
WONDERFUL PEOPLE.
THEY AGREED ON TV.
AND I WAS VERY DISTURBED BY HOW
HE WAS SLIMED BY DAVE
McCORMICK.
DAVE McCORMICK WAS ALSO A VERY
ATTRACTIVE GUY.
SELF-MADE MULTIMILLIONAIRE.
HE IS A BRONZE STAR.
GOING UP WITH MEHMET OZ.
A LOT OF IT WAS MUSLIM HATE.
FAMILY BORN.
PARENTS WERE FROM TURKEY.
OZ SERVED IN THE TURKISH ARMY.
I FOUND THAT EXTREMELY
DISTASTEFUL.
I FELT VERY BAD THAT HE HAD TO
ENDURE THOSE ATTACKS BUT VERY
UNFAIR ATTACKS BUT I.
I WANT TO SEE ONE OTHER THING.
WHEN I WAS A KID, ELECTION DAY
WAS A DAY.
ONE DAY.
YOU GO TO VOTE.
MOST PEOPLE WHEN IN PERSON TO
VOTE OLDER OR DISABLED PEOPLE
NOW I AM PROBABLY AMONG THEM
TAKES THAT ABSENT THE --
ABSENTEE BALLOTS.
THAT NIGHT, YOU COULD GATHER
AROUND THE TV AND YOU KNEW WHO
WON BECAUSE THE ABSENTEE
BALLOTS, THE PROVISIONAL
BALLOTS, ALL THESE PALLETS WERE
-- AFTER THE DISASTER OF THE
HANGING CHAD, NOW YOU GET THE
ACCOUNT.
YOU KEEP THE RUNNING TALLY OF
THE PEOPLE WHO FELT FAIRLY AND
ELECTION DAY, YOU DO IT, THIS
TORTURE MAKES PEOPLE LOSE LATE
IN THE SYSTEM.
>> AND WE GET BETTER RATINGS.
>> EVEN WHEN IT IS IN THAT
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
>> BETWEEN 11:00 AND 12:00 P.M.
>> OH, RIGHT.